you de s'excuser aujourd'hui on se
retrouve pour la suite devant deux
cousines ont été donc ici à la pyramide
illuminati et bord des jeunes me retaper
tout jeu parce que ya pas de sauvegarde
le niveau il ya les pièges le niveau
flapi squeeze j'ai tout refait le début
il ya les noix de cajou qui tombe dessus
race et le pire c'est parti pour les
niveaux illuminati je vais récupérer
malacca ainsi que mes fraises tagada
illuminati me voilà je propose mes
services de doubleurs à tous ceux qui
volent des voix off nul le ce qu'il va
parler aux stages fait le mec ensuite il
se passe ce à quoi sert honteux
vous dirigez 80 cents sur cette photo en
plus alors semaine passage pour la peine
non plus jamais la bla bla aaa
[ __ ] je crie haché quoi je suis désolé
c'est que cette à aa
d'abord il s'est lâché löw sur le nougat
volant qui nous permet de la déformer
ça veut dire ok j'adore la musique on
sera vraiment dans le qg des illuminati
quang nam et les amis n'importe comment
dans le dans l'éditeur de niveaux il à
cliquer partout après lui doit le
respect un ouais vous respecter tous
valorise yoplait le premier qui parle
mal de valence 23 bat jeu des forces à
aller plateforme à l onu ban a demandé à
cette fois on y croit je soigne un bon
feeling ok c'est là que c'est dur il
faut prendre son temps
je suis mort je suis mort [ __ ] mais
c'est il ya un piège s'assurer le sedum
envolé le matin
barrois plus que tu as je sens que le
niveau est très très longs en plus vu la
barre de santé qu'on a eu c'est bon je
lui gelé on est bien on est bien one ont
tout simplement de la fao a meta
m'énerve c'est quoi la it girl a pu
péter du monde
ok c'est reparti pour le nougat tort
prend le roche au nom c'est quoi ça
c'est plate forme qui glisse roger try
hard rock très raide comme un porc au
monde dans mon dieu du hall au talent
inégalable peau
mika vous ne passerez pas je suis le
lieutenant michael souchez des
illuminati
je dois faire quoi au nom il va mettre
sur la gueule non
j'essaie de le battre jésus ne va pas on
va débuter mon dieu oh mon dieu oh mon
dieu
alors si aulas but de sebo tu fais quoi
mika six ans oui mika regard j'ai ma
faute aux tonga pardon ça y est c les
vacanciers du soleil et la chaleur il
émoustiller le lucas en [ __ ] mais les
niveaux continuent en fait ils gèrent
tellement bien ces vecteurs ses courbes
c'est c'est mou c'est quoi ça il ya un
an ya la lienne mon gars tu es sérieux à
françois dornier désolation non on
demande un 1 1 1
ok holla holla holla holla holla le
pauvre créateur du jeu et doit se dire
ah mais c'est trop facile promis en fait
non valoches pourquoi t'as pas fini avec
une barre en plus cela un homme aimait
cas mais il m'arrive quoi là j'ai besoin
de lui là je suis big lots thibodeau je
suis lui car on y va
non non non bawa malades selon nous tout
ce qu'on craint c'est la lienne et du
coup le mieux c'est d'isoler la lienne
aliens isolation ah ok j'ai voulu passer
au-dessus avoir raté quoi voilà je le
fais avoir [ __ ] wata il a eu un petit
coup au passage quoi tranquillement ah
non non plus fait hockey aaa mais j'en
ai marre de ces [ __ ] d'alien à
arrêter de mettre des petits côtelettes
quand je passe là ça m'énerve ok ok ok
bloqué 1
j'ai tendance à stop alors là alors là
il ya quand même un passage où
effectivement une puissance surnaturelle
a décidé de nous sauver pardon olé olé
j'adore les boules les boules c'est ma
passion c'est maintenant ou jamais pot
la vache pour la bachelot non mais non
lavage je voulais dire lavage parce que
ok ça passe bien ça passe bien voilà on
s'est fait brûler le cul mais c'est pas
grave alors c'est qu'ils prochain vote
oh mon dieu qu'est-ce qui se passe je
t'ai trouvée est temps d'en finir une
bonne fois pour toutes
oui saloperies bordel c'est comme ça
leur prend lavage il va être tellement
dure je le sens holla holla et leur deck
redonner [ __ ] et un euro ça je suis
concentré là je resterai comme un steak
c'est creux donnait m'atteignent pas ils
feraient mieux de les manger
ce serait moi gâcher l'excellent mais en
fait si tapie sur espacepro to kiss me
laffont comme la veille un petit lac de
baudreix à paris qui t'aident par l'amci
la route ou en l'occurrence no border il
appelle des aliens temps mais là c'est
la guerre quoi un [ __ ] c'est chaud
c'est chaud là au module s'excite il
s'agissait qu'est ce qui t'a il excite
qui s'excitent eux qu il en peut plus
envoie-t-on kamehameha les mèches toi ok
crabe le kamehameha était en plein show
bat avec son guide du routard comme ça
où est la pire ami la hat hacker
allez c'est bon là cette fois on va s'en
débarrassent heures à la halle est un
pardon non mais c'est abusé quoi ses
crocs de la tête chercheuse quoi oh là
là on n'a plus de mission réussie avec
haïti produit on est quand même bien ce
qui les rend la balle
j'aime pas qu'on ait pas son excitation
bas
ah ah ouais j'espère qu'on va le
défoncer un moment c'est ce permis bien
là allanon le défaut ont sauvegardé ya
naoto kan voit son petit rire à dacca et
on est bien on est bien on est bien on
est bien celle ci tombera pas on craint
pas son excitation nous et si ça vous
excite nous étions excités allez allez
monsieur rhinopharyngite laissez moi en
paix je comprends plus rien je me suis
jeté dessus
c'est la fin il explose en plein de
petites crottes de nez qui s'évapore bon
sens j'ai sauvé la planète
je sauvais world of squeeze c'est la fin
c'est fini fin aux anges aurait aimé
jouer encore longtemps aux crocs bien
joué le screamer tu n'aurais jamais quoi
dû finir c'est comme la troceo sinon
pour dire une phrase ce jeu paul
question du tass a maintenant tout est
glauque et noir si je fais jouer boîte
donner des frissons
c'est quoi pixmania présentes qui se
passe bordel oh mon dieu je peux me
balader carrément dans le dans le menu
quoi il est doué ce valoches en effet
des petites oreilles et tous
tu ne peux pas t chapet tu tapes à un
gros délire l'avalanche et la voilà
maintenant on est dans les bas-fonds du
jeu un peu plus barré bah écoute et
merci à vous regarder cette vidéo encore
merci avalanche qui a fait le jeu
c'était super cool au nom le casque
cassé j'ai adoré le fait qu'eric est
qu'on puisse vraiment lui mettre des
coups de beats ben j'ai adoré le fait
qu'ils ouais vraiment tous les
personnages qu'on a créé et qui soit
dans le jeu c'était super cool et bien
né sais pas mais la vidéo ça vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à remercier ma loge
peut-être qu'on aura d'autres jeux basés
sur l'univers armes un jour on verra
merci à vous d'avoir regardé on se
retrouve très bientôt dans une prochaine
vidéo et puis j'oublie de but
bien vous portez vos valises à
l'aéroport c'est une phrase où j'essaie
de rattraper plus ténue portez vous bien
voilà tout simplement merci d'avoir
gardé tout le monde pis